one they fund 12 times as much 12
billion dollars a year
compared to the government of nutrition
science that shows candy is great for
weight loss for kids
and the soda is not linked to obesity
which is just nonsense right
they co-op professional societies like
the american heart association
the academy of nutrition dietetics and
fund
their organizations the nutrition
organization gets 40
of their funding from the food industry
and in their annual conference
you're not allowed to take pictures in
the exhibit hall because they don't want
people to see all the junk food that
they're promoting
i'm dave rubin and this is the reuben
report and joining me today is a doctor
who is a leader in the field of
functional medicine
as well as a 13-time new york times
best-selling author
uh and his newest book is food fix how
to save our health our economy our
communities and our planet
one bite at a time dr mark hyman welcome
to the reuben report
thanks for having me dave i think that
was my longest intro ever
i mean this is a seriously updated
because that book just hit the list
yesterday
yeah that was i'm doing this on the fly
man you can see as i edited it right
there
it said 12 on the on the property
i'm super psyched to talk to you because
as i just said to you before we started
getting away a little bit from politics
is always a nice break for me yes
but this is not purely a way from
politics so we're gonna do a little of
that
food is probably the most political
issue of our time even though we don't
talk about it that way
yeah and and quite literally you bit off
a lot in this title because you talk
about
economics and communities and the planet
and all of those things
and how it's related so before we get
into any of that stuff
how did you get into this field what
made you care about all of this stuff
where did it all come from that's great
well i've always been interested in
health nutrition i grew up
in spain my parents lived there for 11
years after the war they missed the
whole junk food fast food
processed food revolution america and i
always grew up eating real whole food
and in college i lived with a guy who
was a nutrition phd student
and he introduced me this whole idea
about nutrition against disease
and i became a yoga teacher before as a
doctor then i became a doctor and kind
of got indoctrinated
literally and became
very focused on you know traditional
good medicine but i realized the limits
of it and i
then got sick myself and ended up having
to fix myself using functional medicine
which is looking at systems
looking at root causes and after 30
years of sitting in my office seeing
chronically ill patients
which by the way is 6 out of 10
americans have a chronic disease
that kills 11 million people a year from
food
i realized that food was causing my
patients to be sick
and that i had to look at why they were
eating the food they were eating
and then i thought well it's the food
system i'm like well why do we have the
food system it's our food
policies and why do we have our policies
it's because of the food industry
influence driving our policies and some
of its legacy from good intentions that
we still have from policies fifteen to
seven years ago so
occurred to me that and i really want to
cure my patients
i have to step back and look at the big
picture of what's wrong with our food
system
the impact it's causing on disease on
our economy
on social justice issues poverty mental
health kids academic performance
national security environment climate
it's all one problem that is
predominantly driven by our food and our
food system and it's fixable
if food is the cause it's also the cure
and that's exactly what this book is
about um it's called food fix not food
we'll see about that give me another 50
minutes here um
so you know i i had your buddy max
lugavir on absolutely
and he was also talking about how fun
how regular western medicine when his
mom
got sick they did not have enough
answers or it was as he calls it
diagnose and adios
you you just referenced something there
about indoctrination and
uh relative to western medicine and how
they don't really talk about food can
you explore that a little bit yeah one
barry says you know the food system
produces food with no paying no
attention to health and the
health care system treats disease with
no attention to food
and i think food is the biggest driver
of chronic disease it's something that
i've learned as as a functional medicine
doctor that food is medicine
and can heal but it also can harm and so
that's really why i wrote this book was
to sort of help
our country and hopefully our global
population
understand that if we want to deal with
some of the biggest crises we're facing
today
in america and globally we have to focus
on the food system it's the most
invisible cause
it's there's no real conversation about
it in the political discourse
and yet it's probably the biggest
political issue of our time so since
we're having the conversation right now
what are some of just like the basic
things we should know
about the foods we're eating and and
what we're being force-fed that we
shouldn't
eat and maybe some things that right all
that exactly so how we grow food from
the seed
to how we produce food and process food
to how we eat it
and how we waste it is driving so much
of our issues
so the food we're producing
predominantly today is what we call
ultra
processed calories or ultra processed
food what is that
it's food made from a few simple
ingredients refined white flour
high fructose corn syrup and other corn
additives and ingredients
and refined soybean oil that are turned
into literally hundreds of thousands of
processed foods
that are all made from the same
ingredients that are different colors
sizes and shapes of
food like extruded substances yeah and
and and the
frightening thing is the data they're
not fresh that's what you're calling
they're not fresh
they're ingredients you might even
recognize you read if you cover the
front
of a pop-tart or a corn dog of the box
you probably could barely tell the
difference in the ingredients right
and and these are foods that are made
because the government helps support
these commodity crops which are 60
of our calories the people consume them
the most are the sickest
globally it kills 11 million people a
year that's like a holocaust
every single year people dying from
eating the wrong foods and not eating
the right foods
it's because our whole agricultural
system has been moved to make those
foods
which are causing heart disease diabetes
cancer
dementia obviously obesity and it's
frightening to me when i was
born there were five percent of
americans who were obese
when i graduated medical school it was
less than 20 percent there was not a
single state that had an obesity rate
over 20 percent
now it's 42 and most states have obesity
rates over 40 percent
that's 42 of americans are obese 75
overweight
it's going to be one in two people in 10
years that will be obese not just
overweight
and this is crippling our economy we now
have
one in three dollars in medicare that's
spent for diabetes alone
our entire chronic disease epidemic 80
of medicare costs
are from chronic disease we have
one in three federal dollars that are
spent on medicare
soon it will be one in two i mean
medicare for our company would be the
biggest company in the world with a 1.3
trillion dollar a year budget wow and
and
a lot of that is unnecessary 80 of that
is unnecessary
this caused by the food and the food
system so you mentioned the way our
policies going back
decades sort of led to some of these um
is there like a moment yeah so here's
what happened you know nobody was like a
big cabal of evil food companies that
got together because i think that i'm
glad you started with that because i
think that's what people think that it's
it's like these evil companies or the
evil government that sit down and how do
we screw over the most amount of people
it's the unintended consequences of good
intentions right
so after the world war ii there was a
lot of hunger in the world
there was a need to produce a lot of
starchy calories which we thought were
good
sources of carbohydrates and energy to
fuel a growing population
and so industrial agriculture came onto
the scene
with you know mass mechanization with
intensive use of fertilizers pesticides
herbicides
which no one knew were bad at the time i
mean silent spring was written in the
60s by rachel carson which exposed the
harm of ddt and pesticides
that wasn't eliminated until the 70s uh
and we didn't know that fertilizer was
destroying oceans and lakes and rivers
and
killing you know hundreds of thousands
of tons of fish every year and they're
going to
like nobody know i mean nobody yeah i
don't i don't believe that people really
said oh these pesticides are going to
kill people we're going to use them
anyway or that
glyphosate is going to cause cancer and
destroy your microbiome and
you think these companies they really
yes they thought they had answers
yeah of course and we needed to create a
food for a growing population
but then people started to understand
these things and then the
cat was out of the bag and they didn't
want to lose the the business and the
profitability of
growing food in this way so and there's
been over the last 40 years incredible
consolidation of the food industry from
hundreds of seed companies to like
four major companies that control sixty
percent of our seeds
we've had many fertilizer companies that
are consolidated into a few fertilizer
companies
we have about nine or ten big food
companies and known all the other
companies like
you know haagen-dazs is owned by you
know danone right or nestle you know or
you know danone owns or unilever owns
ben and jerry's so
we don't really understand how much even
in the healthy food brands that these
big companies own
and so we have this sort of this this
juggernaut that has
hit our population our economy and our
politics in ways that
i don't think anybody really still
understands because it's so fast like
even when i graduate like i said
graduate medical school this wasn't a
problem
and within the last 30 years it's just
exploded and
and now we're seeing six out of 10
americans like i said who have a chronic
disease
that's caused by food so we we didn't
have a bunch of bad people doing bad
things
but now we have people trying to protect
their turf
uh but i see change i i'm hopeful
because companies like nestle
the known unilever general mills they're
saying kellogg's are saying no we're
going to change what we're doing right
general mill said we're going to commit
a million acres to regenerative ag
danone says
we're going to pay farmers to convert
from traditional farming
to what's called regenerative ag which
actually fixes a lot of these problems
uh unilever said we're not going to
advertise to kids anymore
ice cream right they're one of the
biggest ice cream producers right uh
even burger king oh no they're not
turning against ice cream are they no
they're not but
they're saying we're not gonna weakness
we're not gonna sell crap to kids
right because that's one of the biggest
things that the food industry does is
they spend billions marketing junk food
to kids which hooks them young
it causes them to have learning
disabilities cognitive impairment
poor academic performance be able to
uh less likely to go to college earn
poor incomes have more chronic disease
and and they're really really in a way
kind of predatory on children and it's
it's terrifying to me because we're
threatening our future generation we're
threatening our global economic
competitiveness
uh we're threatening our ability to
actually have good national security
because 70
of their recruits for the military are
rejected because they're unfit to fight
it's a
a national security threat that the
generals and admirals have written
a report saying unhealthy and unprepared
i mean just from
just from the war in iraq and
afghanistan there were 70 plus percent
more evacuations for obesity-rated
related injuries than for war injuries
think about that incredible that
actually almost doesn't sound it doesn't
sound possible and then i just talked to
a woman
who works at the top level in the
department of defense a couple of days
ago she said
on on the military bases that are just
loaded with fast food restaurants
the combat troops are not combat ready
because they become so unfit so that's
well how do you get from knowing that
this stuff ain't right to having all
these fast food joints on the
combat bases well just like they have
fast food in schools they have
mcdonald's monday and taco bell tuesday
and wendy's wednesday
80 of contracts of the schools have
contracts with soda companies
uh you know these companies are very
smart and deliberate so
while there may not have been bad
intentions to start there is a lot of
bad behavior now
they they have a massive way of
controlling the narrative about food
and confusing consumers confusing
scientists and confusing politicians
one they fund 12 times as much 12
billion
a year compared to the government of
nutrition science that shows candy is
great for weight loss for kids
and the soda is not linked to obesity
which is just nonsense right
they co-op professional societies like
the american heart association
the academy of nutrition dietetics and
fund
their organizations the nutrition
organization gets 40
of their funding from the food industry
and in their annual conference
you're not allowed to take pictures in
the exhibit hall because they don't want
people to see all the junk food that
they're promoting
right uh they fund the american heart
association which allows them to say
trix
are a heart-healthy food because it's
low in fat i mean it's it's frightening
they create front groups
four companies spend half a billion
dollars on
front groups to confuse consumers saying
that for example
uh that pesticides and high fructose
corn syrup and trans fats and smoking
are not bad for you like the american
council on science and health
they spent 30 million dollars fighting
gmo labeling in california
when they won that battle they fund
social groups like the naacp and
hispanic federation so they co-opt
the very groups that are most affected
by these conditions like diabetes and
obesity
so they will oppose things like soda
taxes they were the one of the biggest
opposition groups to the big gulp
uh recommendations from michael
bloomberg which i think was an
ill-advised idea but still they were
opposing it
right because they were funded by these
groups
they fund nutritionists and dietitians
to go on social media
saying we shouldn't have soda taxes or
that soda's okay
i mean it's it's just insidious and then
they fund the political process
so just on one bill the gmo labeling
bill
which is was euphemistically called the
dark act denying americans the right to
know
they spent 192 million dollars in one
year on one bill
they spent half a billion dollars on the
farm bill which is
governing most of our food programs like
food stamps they fund feeding america
which is a
hunger group which is great a hunger
advocacy group to make sure we deal with
hunger in america
on the board of that group are high
level
executives from the food industry which
is why they oppose
restricting food stamps for soda
or other junk food right so now
government is paying
seven billion dollars a year the single
biggest light item for food stamps for
soda for the poor
that's 30 billion they get sicker than
back to the medicare problems
and the true cost of food is not in the
price we pay at the checkout counter
so you buy a can of soda well let's look
at what happens to the corn from the
record i'm off the soda
good i just feel that i have to tell you
that i haven't had a regular soda and
god knows how long
so so here's here's just absolutely
clubs here's how the
the the sort of connectivity works in
corn so yeah
government funds the subsidies that
support corn production
these mono crops that are heavy use of
fertilizers
pesticides herbicides
that corn production itself destroys the
soil
causes release of carbon into the
atmosphere soil
carbon is a third of all the carbon in
the atmosphere from the wavy farm
and contributing to climate change it it
actually destroys the ecosystem
pollinators and bees are killed who's
paying for that right
it destroys the rivers lakes and oceans
as i mentioned and creates dead zones
because of the fertilizer runoff
then the food that's produced is the raw
materials for junk food and for soda
then we pay for that to be
given at the tune of about 75 billion a
year to the poor
in food stamp products seventy-five
percent of that is junk food seven
ten percent of soda so they eat that and
then we pay for medicare medicaid
on the back end when they have diabetes
and obesity related
illnesses and so we're we're not paying
for the economic of the
the impact on our environment and
climate where
we're paying for it literally four times
and that price is not in the can of coke
it should be maybe a hundred dollars for
canada coke when you
include all those costs right okay you
gave me a lot there
yeah sorry first i have to jump back for
a second you you're calling it danone i
always thought it was dannon yeah
in america standing in europe oh okay
now
all right all right that was sticking
with me this whole time so i'm glad we
got yeah i got it
got the important thing out of the way
you say tomato i say tomato
okay so you did grow up in spain now
right now
it's a european company so that's how
they say it okay fair enough uh
that actually is perfect segue to my
next question which is how much of this
is uniquely an american problem oh my
god
yes we have basically created the worst
diet in the world
and are exporting it to every country on
the planet and what's frightening to me
is you know i was in china in 1984.
there was no obesity
there was no diabetes now they
have a hundred plus million diabetics in
china
it's it's the number one country in the
world with diabetics
they're exactly that's probably just a
numbers game though right just because
the amount of
no it used to be one in 50. oh okay so
now it's one in 10. okay so per
yeah it's one in ten yeah india is
number two and in the middle east it's
you know one in four have diabetes
uh in the developing world eighty
percent of the diabetics
and and obesity related issues and
chronic disease are in the developing
world
80 so in countries like
africa in india and china junk food fast
food is aspirational
if you want to take your date out in
america for a good time you don't take
her to mcdonald's
but that's what they do in the
developing world
is a premium brand mcdonald's is a
premium band domino's is a premium brand
my brother-in-law was living in el
salvador doing some work some research
work down there
and we went down there and basically you
know i saw wendy's and there was a lot
of wendy's i think it was wednesday
wendy's
and a couple other chain things and
those were the night that's where
everyone wanted to go because that was
sort of thought of as the nice stuff
yeah which is a very backwards
note and thank god for you and these
kinds of shows because this kind of
conversation wouldn't happen on
traditional tv
i was watching good morning america the
other day and i was in a green room
about to go on a show and i don't
watch tv and there was a whole segment
where they gave free wendy's
breakfast burgers or whatever the junk
they'd give them to the entire audience
and then they were talking about these
great wendy's breakfast things
and they were eating the hosts were
eating them right they had a big ad
after
and it's like you know the host would
never eat that stuff normally
no they wouldn't but but but the media
is co-opted who funds the media and
advertising today
big pharma and food big food right
that's where you see most of the ads
well right every ad now is for a
prescription drug
right and half that is about telling you
the bad stuff that it's going to do and
they should have that when they
advertise food
you know you can eat this and here's all
the side effects right right right
and they do that in cigarettes you go
you go to uh you know i love when you go
to europe or other countries
half the packet is yeah this will kill
you if you use it as directed yeah
i mean with pictures yeah it's like it's
gruesome like i mean it's like wow like
it's not like some little
thing on the side of a cigarette packet
it's like the front of the packet is
like
smoke this and you will die yeah up to
you yeah so so when you talk about
obesity rates and and the unique
american
problem that we have here that now is
being exported when someone talks to you
about the american diet
like what would you say is the average
american diet give me the three meals a
day
and then whatever else you're filling in
between the three it's called the sad
diet the standard american diet yeah
it's so sad
right give me that sad first of all
americans have dessert for breakfast
and and and that means bagels muffins
croissants cereal cereal is a toxic food
it's 75
sugar mostly yeah right we eat i
shouldn't have done a bowl of fruity
pebbles this morning
definitely not no i'm just kidding i had
i had you'll be very happy to know
i had uh i had two organic eggs with
grass-fed butter
there you go protein you got protein and
fat which is what we should be eating
for breakfast
not uh sugary starchy carbs so flour
which is most of our breakfast products
are actually
the worst for your blood sugar than
table sugar so
whether you're eating you know a bagel
or a bowl of sugar below the neck your
body doesn't know the difference
right so that's the first thing that
americans do is huge amounts of starch
and sugar
for lunch you know they'll have
sandwiches burgers fries
soda a dinner you know again most people
in this country 60 of their calories
come from processed food
and even if they're eating at home which
is only 50 percent of the time
it's usually from a box a package or
some industrial
product is that right only so only 50
percent of americans are eating dinner
at home meaning maybe evening or they're
50
of americans eat out wow you know half
the time like so it's half the time
i'm sorry half our meals are eating now
wow uh in in 1900 it was two percent of
our meals
people don't know how to cook uh you
remember you know the whole you deserve
a break today
it was not an accident the food industry
deliberately in this in the 50s and 60s
when there was this advent of a backlash
against processed food
there was a woman named betty who was a
homec teacher
who decided she wanted to go around and
advocate for
families to learn how to cook and grow
gardens and eat whole food
and the this big cabal of food companies
got together in minnesota general mills
and others
and basically concocted this idea that
we should create
convenience as a value in food
and they they invented somebody called
betty crocker
who i thought was a real person my
mother had the betty crocker i
swear to you that until you just said
that yeah i've always thought yeah and
it had her picture there was like a
cartoon picture of betty crocker eddie
crackers on the front of the cookbook
wait if you remember mine is real though
right uh i don't know
but but but if you oh man that was a guy
i know he was
but i remember those recipes and i i
think my mother still had that cookbook
she died but i think i still have it
and look at the recipe it says crumble a
row of
ritz crackers on top of your broccoli
casserole right
add one can of campbell's cream of
chicken soup to the
sauce or whatever and so it was
insinuating processed foods and then it
became
you know tv dinners and then it became
more and more processed foods
and and literally we've hijacked the
food interest hijacked the american
kitchen
has created two generations of americans
who don't at cook who watch more cooking
on tv
than they actually spend time cooking
yeah and and and
have created a generation of people who
are dependent on
industrial processed food that's made in
factories so when you then add in
sort of a generation now of i want
everything fast
no matter what and i can have everything
delivered uber eats and everything else
uh people just it's a secondary problem
to have to fight it's not that it's also
it's just that it's so accessible it's
just that we now no longer expect
to have to put any work into anything i
i've come to love cooking now
yeah i mean it's it's it's it's
something if you have a human body
it's a basic life skill like like
brushing your teeth or
taking care of the basic functions of
your life if you don't know how to cook
you're at a disadvantage
unless you're rich enough to have a chef
great you know but yeah that's not most
of us
right right and there's a myth out there
that cooking is hard
that it's complicated that takes too
much time that eating whole foods is too
expensive
and these are the mantras of the food
industry that we have bought and
and and we have consumed and believe and
it's just not true
and i've demonstrated this over and over
in various communities
where where people can do it in it even
in the worst environment so just a quick
story
i was part of this movie fed up about
how the food industry was driving sugar
consumption and led to this whole
obesity problem and they were profiling
a family in south carolina
that i went to their house i was a
trailer where they lived with a family
of five the father was 42
had diabetes on dialysis couldn't lose
the weight to
be able to get a kidney a new kidney
because we're very overweight the mother
was
this big the sun was 16 and almost
diabetic
and they never cooked a meal in their
life and i went into their trailer and i
pulled everything out and i showed them
what they were eating and they thought
it was all healthy they thought it was
you know
cool whip which is a healthy topping but
this has zero trans fat on the label
because
the government gave the food industry a
loophole which says
if it was less than half a gram per
serving it's a zero trans fat
but you'll get ingredient list it's like
high fructose corn syrup
trans fat right and so i showed them all
this stuff they were shocked
and i said okay let's cook a meal from
simple ingredients and i'm on the
board of the environmental working group
and there's a guide called good food on
a tight budget
how to eat well for you eat well for
your wallet and for the planet
and it's ingredients that are real food
but they're less expensive so what are
the less expensive cuts of meat the less
expensive vegetables and the less
expensive things you can buy in
beans and grains and so forth and we
cooked a simple meal they loved it
they i said here's a guide here's my
cookbook you guys can do this
and they lived in one of the worst food
deserts in america on food stamps and
disability
for a thousand bucks a month for three
for a family of five
to eat right so they did it and they
lost 200 pounds as a family wow
the sun ended up losing 50 but gained it
back because he went to work at
bojangles and said it was like putting
an
alcoholic to work in a bar right right
and then he finally got his act together
and he lost 138 pounds
his family never gone to college or
anything he asked me for a lot of
recommendation for medical school and
now he's in medical school
so it's possible and they did it in one
of the worst food deserts in america
but it was just education people just
don't understand how to do it they don't
know how to choose
and and to eat healthy food it doesn't
have to be more expensive
it's shown that you can actually for 50
cents more a day
or 15 dollars a month per person you can
eat whole real food diet and sometimes
let's unpack that a little bit because
you hear people say oh well you know the
reason poor people have to eat fast food
is because you know it's eight bucks and
you're getting the burger you're getting
the fries you're getting the cookie blah
blah blah
but i do find now since i've become much
more aware of all this
if you have eight bucks you can eat a
pretty damn good meal that you could get
at trader joe's
or a local thing that you you might have
to heat it up for a second
or do something so can you lay out a
couple ways that you could change your
diet well you know on a really economic
level first of all you know
chickens are not that expensive there
are certain cuts of meat that are not
that expensive
i mean you can even get regenerately
raised grass-fed beef if you buy
directly from the rancher
for an average of eight dollars a pound
or two dollars a serving
which is less than a mcdonald's
hamburger oh i bet you could even at
whole foods here i think it's only
now 5.99 a pound yeah for wait what do
you say regenerative regeneratively
raised beef which is grass-fed but it's
a whole next level of how do you restore
soil and talk about climate reversal and
all that mm-hmm so it's like a next one
so that's next level past just great
doesn't even like the next level up yeah
it doesn't really exist out widely but
okay but you can you can buy vegetables
that aren't
like heirloom you know radishes from
japan or something but you can buy
carrots and onions and cabbage and
you know small potatoes you can buy real
whole food
and you can make grains and beans which
are extremely cheap
whole grains if you know how to make it
and you can make delicious food
and people just have no clue how to shop
and buy and find the right foods and
there's great resources out there where
you can
bypass the middleman like thrive market
or you can buy
really good ingredients for 50 to 25
percent of 50 off of the retail price
that you can get at whole foods
right there's lots of ways is that
because they're either uh
close to expiration no it's a membership
it's a membership program
so they make money on memberships like
costco it's sort of like costco means
whole foods meets amazon
interesting a lot of big business in on
this yeah
um okay so people start cleaning up
their diets and they start
losing weight but what do they have to
do after that to kind of keep this
thing going well i think what we have to
realize is that
um we need we need change right food fix
the book i wrote is
about what what the problems are and how
they're connected
and what the solutions are and there's
citizen solutions
there's things that businesses can do
there's things that
governments need to do so nothing is
going to
work unless it's all happening yeah all
right so let's let's do one at a time
what we already have yes
the citizens of citizens so citizens can
choose what they eat so
if imagine if everybody in america just
ate food
from real ingredients from whole foods
it doesn't have to be whole foods
the whole paycheck could be just real
food yeah
we got rid of industrial ingredients so
i'm going to not eat refined white flour
i'm not going to eat high fructose corn
syrup i'm not going to eat
refined soy bean oil and i'm not going
to eat any foods with weird ingredients
that are coming from
these plants that you can look at the
label and if you don't recognize it you
can't pronounce it or it's in latin
or it has 45 ingredients don't eat it
right so let's just give some people
some real things to eat in the morning
have some eggs
yeah eggs have some eggs yeah have some
steel cut oats yeah
you know have uh yogurt if you want uh
berries nuts seeds all that's great okay
um a shake second is is uh
don't eat gmo if you can avoid it why
not necessarily because we know gmo
foods are bad for your health
but we do know that the stuff they put
on them is bad like the pesticides and
the glyphosate
which causes cancer that's weed killer
and cheerios
there's more weed killer in your
cheerios than there is vitamin d and b12
which they add
to the cereal wow and and that's why
kellogg's has said we're going to get it
out
can you explain the gmo thing a little
bit more we've talked a bit about this
on the show but gmo genetically modified
organisms in and of themselves aren't
bad right
we don't know that process we don't know
i think it's a big uncontrolled
experiment on humanity
so but haven't we gen uh modified like
bananas for years to get them to be a
certain
yes we we definitely have
bread plants for years mendon is peas
that's different than
inserting genes into plants that are
novel to that plant
so we don't we don't know but we do know
that the stuff they put on them
is bad so glyphosate is a great example
weed killer
okay it it's uh put on 70 of our crops
it's 3.5 billion pounds that we've
sprayed on america since it's been
introduced
it's 70 percent of all the chemicals in
agriculture used
across the world it is been
by the committee that was gathered
from international scientists as part of
the un's
uh sorry the who's research on what
cancer is and what's carcinogenic
they said that it's a problem carcinogen
there have been
billions of dollars of lawsuits that
have been won
against glyphosate in court recently
because
of its link to non-hodgkin's lymphoma
and that has led to a
35 billion loss in stock price and also
the firing of the ceo of bear which
bought monsanto which makes a weed
killer
that also is clearly linked to
destruction of the microbiome which is
the most important thing in your body
that controls everything this is the
gut bacteria that controls heart disease
cancer diabetes obesity
autoimmune disease allergies it
literally destroys your microbiome
and you're getting that all the time in
your food it's sprayed on 70 crops of
wheat on all wheat products it's sprayed
right at the end of harvest
so they dry it out so they can harvest
it easier and
it's in your food so it's not good for
you so whether or not gmo
is bad or not if you don't eat gmo foods
you're telling a message to the
marketplace
to stop what they're doing and
campbell's recently announced
they're getting all gmo out of their
food chain right so
and so so kellogg's announced they're
getting glyphosate out of their cereal
which is
which is happening because the consumers
want change
can you explain a bit more on
so we use these chemicals it's not just
that it's getting into the food but then
the runoff into the water yeah so i mean
so so 75 look
agriculture depends on pollinators right
butterflies bees
we've lost 75 percent of our bodies
because
the things that they use for pesticides
are neurotoxic and they kill pests and
they don't discriminate between bees
or potato beetles right and so so
they're they're really destroying our
pollinators which has enormous impact
and the fertilizer
and but that's not even to mention the
human impact so
there's a study for example of kids who
are exposed to pesticides
it's led to a loss of 41 million iq
points
it increases the risk of cancer and
dramatically it causes 10 to 20 000
deaths a year in farm workers from
pesticide poisoning
so it's it's a it's a real human cost
but then there's a fertilizer story
which is
you know a whole different game and i i
was sort of shocked as a doctor start to
dig into this
uh and can i just kind of expand on it
for me so that's what we're doing here
i actually didn't think fertilizers are
so bad i'm like so you put a little
nitrogen on the soil what's the big deal
it helps the plants grow
turns out that about two percent of all
energy use
in the world is for making fertilizer
it's made
using natural gas that comes from
fracking they're the biggest purchaser
of natural gas
wow the fertilizer industry because it's
a very energy intensive process to make
it
and then um the methane uh released from
the fracking wells
is about 40 to 50 percent more methane
than that released from traditional oil
wells then you put it on the soil
and it causes nitrous oxide to be
produced which is 300 times more potent
greenhouse gas and carbon dioxide and it
destroys also the microbiome of the
soils the microbiology
which is how our plants get nutritious
so what we're eating today
is far less nutritious than before you
eat broccoli today it's got 50 less
nutrition than it did 50 years ago
because of the soil requiring the
microbiology to extract the nutrients
that the plants eat
is that why my mom always says you can't
get a good tomato anymore that's right
is there something right is there
something 100 100 so it's all dependent
on the
soil and then and then once it's runs
off into the water into the rivers lakes
and oceans
it fertilizes the algae because it's
indiscriminate that's why i see these
algal blooms in lake erie and why toledo
had no fresh water and
cost the city a billion dollars to
provide water to its
citizens and then it runs off into the
gulf of mexico
through the mississippi and and creates
a dead zone the size of new jersey that
kills 212 thousand metric tons of fish
and there's 400 of these around the
world that
uh are are the size of europe
that 500 million people depend on for
food every year
and it's it's 400 billion pounds of this
[ __ ] that's
poured on on the earth and these
companies are
super powerful and they're nefarious
they started something called
climate smart agriculture now who's not
first climate scientist sounds good
i know if it sounds good it's
automatically good right crop life you
know yeah like all these front groups
and so they create these
like the global alliance on sustainable
agriculture it's all big food in big ag
and they and the major contributors and
partners in the climate smart
agriculture movement
are fertilizer companies so it's
interesting though because on one hand
you're saying some of these companies
have started to do
yes they have things and then on the
other hand clearly it's a mixed bag
right
some people are fighting for you know
survival and claw and
tooth and nail the grocery manufacture
of america which represented a lot of
the big food companies
was pretty nefarious in its tactics to
obstruct any progress on changing our
food system for the better
so they for example in washington state
spent a huge amount of money
on fighting gmo labeling and they did it
in a way
by creating funding from the food
companies through a
mechanism that was illegal and it was it
was a it was the biggest illegal
campaign finance
violation ever uh the state of
washington sued them
for 18 million and won which is
nothing compared to the billions they're
making and the law didn't pass because
their campaign was effective right
and after that a bunch of these
companies like nestle danone
unilever mars they bailed on the grocery
manufacturer america
they started the sustainable food policy
alliance remains to be seen what they're
going to do
but the grocery manufacturers of america
now is defunct everybody started pulling
out because they're just not
acting and great and then they they
perform this new
version of it that's sort of a smaller
version a lot not a lot of members join
now so
that's a good sign that the foodness
you're starting to kind of wake up and
you've got
big companies talking about
sustainability about regenerative ag
about
and then i'm talking about they're
actually doing something about it why
why would they care
it's not responding to the consumer
because only 10 percent of consumers
know about regeneration right i mean
amazon whole foods announced that
regenerative ag was one of the biggest
most important
uh business innovations and and and
trends
and and that that is really important
are they labeling meat now with
regenerative yeah
why can't i say regenerative
regenerative regenerative you can
yes you can so so yeah i don't know if
companies aren't doing it because their
consumers are asking yeah they're doing
it because they realize the way we're
growing our food today
is threatening our future ability to
grow food
so they're like wait a minute we need to
buy these raw materials from the farmers
and if they keep farming this way they
ain't going to be any food for us to buy
and our companies are going to go bad
so they're paying farmers which the
government should be doing
to actually convert to regenerative ag
so so citizens can do a lot with
changing their diet
they can also actually do small things
that actually make a
big difference they can start for
example joining community support
agriculture
they can have a community garden they
can have their own garden they can start
composting
food waste is the third biggest emitter
of greenhouse gases after the u.s and
china
because when you throw all your
vegetables and food scraps
and wasted stuff into the landfill it
rots causing methane
right so yeah you're a vegetarian you're
vegan you think you're not eating meat
and doing a good job you throw out your
vegetable [ __ ] and it goes
in the landfill and you actually you
know it's more methane than
cows produce right so it's it's all
complicated but the key is you could
start doing a compost in san francisco
they have mandatory compost in france
it's mandatory uh in massachusetts
they've
they've created a law that if you're a
company that produces a ton of food
waste
a week you can't throw it out so they
have to figure out what to do with it
give it to farmers or whatever
and this is it spurs business innovation
so those kinds of laws
spurred vanguard renewables to partner
with dairy farmers who are losing money
in massachusetts
because nobody's drinking milk anymore
and they built anaerobic digesters which
basically
they take three tractor trailers from
whole foods and grocery stores every day
on this one farm
and they put it in this in this digester
with cow poop
it basically creates electricity for
1500
homes the farmer gets free electricity
the farmer makes a hundred thousand
dollars a year instead of losing 1600 a
year
vanguard then sends sells it back up to
the grid
and everybody's happy and you solve
manure food waste
and you make electricity and it's just
like and there's a few of these in this
country but there's 17 000 in europe
because they're way ahead of us yeah so
are we just behind on it because of the
power that these big companies have over
legislators or yeah yeah i mean i mean
into the system
yes i mean you know when you look at the
lobby uh effort
um and you look at the different
industries and lobbying it's like
if you look at a graph it's like
agriculture and food is here and
everything else is down here
it's just the massive amount of money
that's pouring in
that is quote educating the lawmakers
about what to do
and they're not hearing the other side
it's not that they're bad people it's
not that they're not well intentioned
is that they just don't know and i've
been meeting with senators and
congressmen and
uh and i just sort of shocked at the
level of awareness of these issues
uh and when you start to talk about it
they get very engaged and interested
so how do you decide how much government
should be involved this is where my the
libertarian side
you always the alarms are going off like
oh yeah we can tell the government to
start giving these regulations
and stop doing this stop doing that and
a we know it someone will always get
around it
the law of unintended consequences
etcetera etcetera so how do you decide
if someone's trying to do this
i think approach it's really about you
know sort of being honest about what
we're doing and how the government is
funding
the growing of food that's making us
sick it's funding
the provision of that food to a large
portion of the population and it's
paying for the medicare and the medicaid
so we need to actually incentivize
the right things and de-incentivize the
wrong things so give
people on snap more benefits for eating
fruits and vegetables and
basically a habit to pay a little more
for buying junk food yeah or
have have them but oddly there's a lot
there's a lot of lefties that are often
against that right
like because they say oh we shouldn't
tell these people what to do with this
well this is this is
but this is not necessarily this is the
this is the
the the hunger groups that are are
funded by the food industry who are on
their boards
who are opposing the changes in snap
regulation
uh why can't we put nutrition guidelines
in food stamps it's a great program
developed by johnson in 64
to deal with food insecurity and hunger
in america great idea
but there are no nutrition guidelines so
for school lunch
there are nutrition guidelines right so
at burger king you literally say
outside sometimes it'll say we accept
snap or we accept this or that
so this is this is a tough one for me on
the libertarian side which like i don't
i wouldn't want
i don't love those programs generally
but i wouldn't want the government then
telling people what they have to eat and
yet i completely understand what we do
we do we
do with school lunch right i think they
should be able to serve uh you know soda
and mcdonald's for every kid's school
lunch
well i would say for kids school lunches
that are given by the government it's
probably a little different rather than
you giving if you're giving people money
for food you want to have them have as
much choice but i get it
i i do get it i'm not saying there
should be no i agree regularly yeah and
then you know
and then for for incentives for farming
for example they could create incentives
for gender back so now there's
regulations
in the usda that if you're if you have a
10 000 acre soybean farm and you want to
grow a
five-acre piece of uh plot for
regenerative vegetables or whatever
you can't do that because the government
will take away all your crop supports if
you grow
vegetables which are thing is specialty
crops so it's just
weird like the government tells us in
our dietary guidelines that 50
of our vegetables should be i'm sorry 50
of our plate
should be fruits and vegetables through
subsidies
we support 4.45
for vegetables so less than half a
percent of our agricultural supports are
for vegetables mostly apples
and and these are called specialty crops
and yet we're telling people to eat
lots of fruits and vegetables and so far
if our plate actually looked like the
government
subsidies were we wouldn't be eating
half our plate of fruits especially
having a giant corn fritter deep-fried
and soybean oil
right uh that with a giant cotton napkin
right well corn is a vegetable
and maybe one green bean right wait
let's talk about corn a little bit
because i always
the high fructose corn syrup one always
strikes me as the craziest thing that if
you buy
a coca-cola in the united states yes uh
i believe
it's the second ingredient and you know
it's water and then it's high fructose
corn syrup yes
if you buy a mexican coke in mexico or
that one that's been brought here
the second ingredient is sugar how did
we in america we're so advanced
and yet we can't even do the sugar thing
well you know even though sugar that
ain't that great for you
i met the vice president of pepsi once
uh vice
chairman of pepsi and we became friends
he's a doctor and you know he
had some interesting conversations and i
said why why do you guys use high
fructose corn syrup he says the
government makes it too cheap for us not
to use it
there's there's all kinds of tariffs on
sugar to prevent importing sugar
to keep the prices you know uh higher
and and to actually help corn farmers
use their products for the
sugar which helps americans but it also
kills americans yeah geez yeah yeah what
is it what a screwy one i mean it's just
it's great it is screwy yeah yeah you go
to a store and you got to pay more for
the sugar one
mm-hmm because the prices are
artificially low right
so uh it's challenging and i think uh we
we kind of have to look at
how do we create uh things that aren't
you know overly
uh onerous for people but that
incentivize them to do the right thing
and disincentivize them to the wrong
thing
right i think that's what what what we
do through our tax code we can
incentivize
our tax code why do we for example pay
allow the food industry to take a 15
billion tax cut
or not pay taxes on marketing junk food
why do we do that i mean cigarettes
there's enormous taxes there's enormous
disincentives you can't advertise
why do we let them do that i mean we can
say free speech fine but why should we
let them
have the benefit of that right so what
what model is better
for us so i see what you're saying so
okay we're exporting a lot of this but
where are the places that are
that have a model that maybe makes a
little more sense just well i mean
listen
europe is so far ahead of us there's no
gmo half the ingredients in our food
that we allow
they don't allow food additives colors
dyes
uh something like azodicarbonamide which
is a yoga mat material
that is used oh isn't that in the rib is
that the one it was in subway
yeah it was in subway buns it was in a
lot of it's a lot of the fast food buns
yeah and and and it's still allowed in
this country it's a
demon as a yoga teacher and a food guy
this must kill you that's right and and
you're in in singapore for example uh
which is a very you know
restrictive country if you use that as a
food manufacturer in your product
you get a 450 000 fine and 15 years in
jail
and we allow it here right products like
bht and
and our are preservatives that are
not allowed in europe there's a whole
list of these in my book of why do we
have
them here or not there uh and and so we
we have to look at how
different countries are addressing this
and europe as collectively as focusing
on regenerative agriculture on changing
their system
chile is is a great example of a country
that has
implemented a whole series of food
policies that have had great impact in
reducing obesity
and ill health which are completely
unpalatable in this country
so the only way it got done was the vice
president of the senate
and the president of the country at the
same time
were doctors and they got this and
they're like we're going to fight the
food industry
so they they put in a ban on junk food
advertising to kids
from six in the morning to live at night
they banned all cartoon characters on
kids food so no more tony the tiger they
killed
toucan sam and tony the tiger slaughter
yeah
they put warning labels on the front of
packaging like cigarettes
for bad food they eliminated advertising
of
formula to kids they eliminated any junk
food in schools
and they put in 18 18 soda tax
and and they've funded there's been
funding to
assess the impact of this 30 million
from bloomberg actually to fund
what this actually is doing and they
found dramatic improvements and the most
dramatic benefit wasn't even from the
soda tax it was from the
ban on marketing and the warning labels
reduced consumption
four times more than soda taxes is the
increasing of taxes on these things is
that
just really a short-term stop though
because eventually if you get enough
people to stop then you don't have the
tax money
anymore and then you might be funding
other things with the tax money
i don't i mean it's been a model that
you know it's very controversial but
uh larry summers and michael bloomberg
create a fiscal task force
around the world of financial finance
ministers to look at how do we use
financial policies to
change behavior right so you you tax the
things you don't want people to do
and you incentivize the things you want
people to do right so
so savings you don't tax uh you know and
maybe soda you should tax
right and i think that it's been
effective across the world it's just
it's just a challenging thing to do the
data is really clear that it works
cigarettes we do it on cigarettes and
we've done in berkeley we've done in
philadelphia we've done it in
many many cities but the problem is the
food industry fights back
so so in uh the last election 2016
four cities in california passed the
soda tax there were six cities totally
uh in the country and and the food
industry freaked out so the big soda
companies then
created us a strategy to prohibit future
taxes
so what they did is for example they
went in california
and they created a ballot measure that
would prohibit local taxes
unless it was a two-thirds majority
which would mean it would [ __ ]
local governments to fund schools to
fund police departments fire departments
and and they didn't care about that but
they spent seven million dollars
funding this campaign that would have
passed because people don't like taxes
right five days before the election they
went to governor brown
who was also called governor moonbeam
probably the most liberal governor in
history
they said if you don't pass this
preemptive
law that prohibits future taxes on soda
and junk food we're going to leave this
ballot measure in
and you're going to be screwed so he
basically was
bullied they made him in quote an offer
he couldn't refuse like the mafia
and he had to pass this tax which now
prohibits future taxes
and they're doing this in state after
state after state so all this happens
behind the scenes yeah
all it can politics is messy yeah and so
so as as consumers we're sort of like
stuck with
uh you know this system that is
perpetuating
a disease-creating system and a
disease-creating economy
uh and it's it's it and it's threatening
our entire
way of life and people just don't get it
it's like if we don't fix this
you know we're all gonna be really sick
and fat and
get all these chronic illnesses which we
already are our economy is going to be
crippled by this
i mean think about it if one in two
dollars of our entire federal budget is
for medicare
i mean like there's no money for
anything else right yeah all right so
we have sick people suddenly from all of
this or i guess not so suddenly it's
happened over generations
we've gotten an economy that the
incentives are completely out of whack
let's talk about that planet thing too
how is this affecting
the planet we've talked a little bit
about yeah so so so here we talk about
some of the environmental impacts but
what you know what people don't realize
is that
um the very way we grow food is
threatening our ability to grow food
because of its impact on our
climate and weather right so so if you
look at end to end our entire food
system
it's 50 of climate change or fossil
fuels is about a third
so it's worse than fossil fuels why
deforestation
you know we kill seven billion trees a
year the size of costa rica
soil erosion from our way of farming and
the tilling factory farming of animals
food waste transport refrigeration all
these things end to end
you add them up and it's 50 the good
news is that
if that's true we can fix it and the u.n
said that if we took two million of the
five million degraded hectares of land
around the world from over grazing and
from
poor farm techniques and we converted to
regenerative agriculture which is a way
of farming that restores and builds soil
that conserves water that increases
biodiversity pollinators et cetera et
cetera produces better food more food
that's more profitable for the farmers
if we did that we could stop climate
change for 20 years
and it would cost 300 billion dollars
which is less
than medicare spends on diabetes every
year in america what does that actually
look like so we go to this land
that's been so far yeah so farmland lp
is i think a private equity company that
is buying up
conventional farms they're converting
them to regenerative agriculture
uh which includes creating diverse
plantings crop rotations
cover crops no tilling of the soil and
integrating animals who poo and pee and
build soil
they have actually taken their profits
on those farms from single digits
to 60 to 70 profits and
they add all these benefits to the
environment we call ecosystem services
so as humans we extract about 125
trillion dollars a year
from nature and use it for our purposes
without putting it back
the global economy is about 80 to 90
trillion so it's a lot
there's a whole concept called ecosystem
services where farmers can actually add
benefit to the environment
build soil conserve water increase
pollinators all that stuff
and they're finding they add 21 million
on the farms that they bought at benefit
versus the conventional farms which
remove eight
million and there are companies like
indigo that are paying farmers through
very high tech measurements of those
benefits to the environment
for the benefit they create in costa
rica they're paying farmers to build
soil and conserve water and increase
biodiversity so the known and and
and and general mills are now paying
farmers to do this so
there's incentives that government could
create to say like we're talking about
carbon capture technology right so the
most
powerful carbon capture technology in
the world is available everywhere
it's free it works better than anything
else
it can completely reverse carbon uh in
the environment and draw down all the
carbon
and it's called photosynthesis and it's
been around for billions of years
yeah i mean that green stuff and the sun
like that when it's sun
and carbon i mean that's how happens
carbon dioxide plants eat that
sunlight turns it into energy it goes
into the roots and into the soil
thirty to forty percent of all the
carbon in our atmosphere which is a
trillion tons about three to four
billion
comes from the destruction of carbon in
the soil from soil erosion from the
tilling from the wave farm
and it can all be put back the soil can
literally hold
three times the amount of carbon in our
entire atmosphere right now
if we were to do it right ah i wish we
had more time here but i got a heart out
today give me give me the one
minute like if you want people to
understand all of this or
the the call to act contact yeah give me
the call first
finish strong first of all uh they can
go to foodfixbook.com
i was going to do that part and there's
a food fix
action guide which lists all the citizen
actions business innovations and
government actions that that can be done
to actually start to solve this
and you can also go to foodfix.org we've
started a campaign a nonprofit and a
lobby group because i
i've decried lobbyists my whole life now
i'm going to become one
because i want to be one for the good
guys yeah and we're raising money we're
we're
mobilizing grassroots efforts we're
educating people we're educating
lawmakers
and if you want to be part of that
movement go to foodfix.org
and and learn more about it and let's do
this together all right dr markham and
we're going to do this again
guys go to drhymen.com or foodfix.org
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about
lifestyles instead of non-stop yelling
check out our
lifestyle playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out our full episode
playlist
they're both right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe
and click the notification bell